[Music]
my name is christian schaefer i'm an
outdoor adventure photographer and i've
been living on the road for just over
three years now first i lived in my suv
for 14 months and then two years ago i
bought this van brand new as an empty
cargo van and hired a team to build it
out so for two years now i've been
living in this van full time along with
some airbnbs and houseits but otherwise
this has been my primary residence in
two years i've put just over 29 thousand
miles on it i've spent most of that time
traveling throughout the western u.s and
i've had some pretty rad experiences and
adventures thanks to this mobile
lifestyle
one example of that is while staying in
jackson wyoming for a couple months i
grabbed coffee with my biggest
inspiration in both photography and road
life jimmy chin he's actually the reason
why i got into outdoor adventure
photography he's like
such a legend so yeah he's actually
filming and i'm gonna show him the van
this place is sick
well first of all this is like one of
the nicest vans i've been in there are a
few things i really liked about this man
though so i just got a tour i mean
i i love the little shelf
i do love this the double layered yeah a
little secret drawer you keep your
sleeping bags in them
and they're so soft because they're
probably like 800 filled down so you can
just drop this into your bed putting in
my man yeah that is so nice
so jimmy actually lived in his car for
seven years while building his career as
a photographer um so not only is he a
legend in the filmmaking and photography
realm he's also an og road lifer and
he's actually building another van right
now so it was cool to show him around
mine and chat about some ideas for his
upcoming build
and it got me thinking that i should
really do an updated fan tour for you
guys since it's been two whole years
since i moved in if you watch my first
van tour then you'll notice i've made
some changes and upgrades so i'll walk
you through those along with some
organization
techniques that i use and
i'll also show you some places where
i've experienced wear and tear after so
much time on the road so
let's jump into it welcome to my tiny
home on wheels this is a 2019 ram
promaster 1500 high roof 136 wheelbase
and i purchased it brand new as an empty
cargo van this entire build was done by
brett and yulia formerly known as gone
with the van unfortunately they're no
longer together as a couple but brett is
still building you can find him on
instagram here and julia started her own
wellness company and you can find her
here um honestly they're such down to
earth genuine and very talented people
so i recommend them whatever they happen
to be creating okay so i'm going to
start by going over a few of the
different materials and structures types
of wood that were used in the build but
if you want something more in depth go
check out the gone with the van channel
they still have some youtube videos up
of
the process and behind the scenes from
when they did this build this entire
space that i call home is just 60 square
feet and i guess we'll start in the
kitchen with my little planter box
[Music]
the type of wood used throughout the van
is poplar and plywood and the
countertops and the table top are birch
hardwood
the floors are engineered hardwood oak
wood floors and the color used
throughout the van is vanilla shake both
the counters and the ceiling were hand
painted to create that distressed look
and the van is insulated throughout with
havelock wool and super r diamond
radiant barrier
here in the kitchen i have white subway
tile as a backsplash and
incredibly this has held up for two
whole years of going down crazy bumpy
roads and nothing has ever cracked or
fallen out the only thing i will point
out is sometimes this caulking needs to
be redone and i have redone that a
couple of times um but you can see it's
starting to yellow a little bit and
there is some
separation there but i would say overall
it's held up so well up here i have a
little book nook with one of my plants
and some journals and my battery pack
for the fairy lights wacom tablet um
there's two layers of books back there
so it's a nice little storage area this
is my dometic fridge it is a crx 55 and
it runs on dc 12 volt
it's the perfect size for one person i
did remove the freezer compartment up
here to make more space for produce but
otherwise it's just everything that i
need and honestly i don't know how i
lived without one when i was in an suv
up here i organized all of my dry goods
got a mason jar for coffee i've got
these little gray bags for produce um
just so i'm always cutting down on
plastic and i don't accumulate too much
garbage um crackers pasta olive oil
that's kind of thing in this cupboard i
keep
a lot of my dishes and my spices
everything is pretty much stacked into
each other and when i take it all out
four plates four bowls a frying pan and
a strainer here is my little spice
container um i've got salt and pepper
trader joe's everything but bagel tea
extra coffee grinds in this little
container i have my coffee filters which
i use with my aeropress this is my
electric water heater which i've had
since my first fan tour and it's super
compact
just opens up like that and it runs off
of my solar in my last van tour a lot of
you guys uh asked specifically about
this electric kettle um so i did create
some affiliate links and now i just have
a page on my website it's christian
shaffer dot art slash gear i'll include
that link in my caption below um and on
that page you'll find all my
recommendations for the stuff i go over
in the van tour today as well as
additional road life recommendations um
photography camera gear camping gear all
of that and if there's something you see
in the tour that you don't find on there
just shoot me a message and i'll let you
know what it is and where i got it this
is a two burner stove which i run off of
propane and the propane is stored in
that cupboard which i'll get to in just
a little bit in this drawer i keep my
utensils so a cutting board smaller
cutting board some towels um ziploc
baggies up here just bamboo utensils
knives all that kind of stuff and
oh good time to mention these rv latches
come in really handy um it connects to
this other half in here and what that
does is when i'm driving
it prevents it from coming out so it's
in there nice and snug and i actually
have those latches on these cupboards
and drawers as well i don't have them up
top because these actually never open up
they've never been an issue but the
latches do come in really handy for
these other covers and drawers down here
in this cabinet i have my power station
and my little bookshelf
but everything in the van is solar
powered and it runs off of either ac or
dc current on the roof of the van i have
two renegy solar panels mounted and
they're 160 watts each so 320 watts
total and down here in the cabinet i
have two battleborn lithium batteries
they're 100 amp hours each so 200 amp
hours total this renegy inverter is 3000
watts which is actually quite powerful
i'm able to curl my hair and charge all
of my camera gear and my laptop many
many times over also i have this dc to
dc charger installed which allows my
house batteries to charge off of my car
battery whenever i'm driving long
distances so throughout the van there
are five 12 volt dimmable light switches
10 12 volt led puck lights five ac
outlets and two usb dc outlets and down
in this cabinet i have these
linen storage boxes in these boxes i
just have a variety of stuff like
cups here's a top for my frying pan
here's a another pan some extra poles
covers for my storage stuff this is a
little art project that i still haven't
gotten around to down here is mostly
camping stuff propane gas for camping an
extra one gallon tank is a backup some
water filtration and this is the cover
for my bare bin which is back there and
next to the bare bin is my propane tank
right now i have a one pound propane
tank inside of the bear canister because
um i haven't installed the propane gas
detector yet but once i get that
installed i will be using that one full
time also side note the bear canister is
super important for when i'm camping off
grid and i
need a place to store trash outside um
just so the critters won't get into it
and so that it won't stink up the van
this white box is prince um since i'm a
photographer i like to keep some of
those on hand and stored next to that
is this which nathaniel made for me it
fits right in my fan up here so that if
i'm at like a rest stop or i'm sleeping
at a walmart i can block out all the
light and have it totally dark in here
right above the kitchen i have this
dometic fan which is great when i'm
cooking and also on a hot day
has two different settings so when i
open that up and put it on high
open up these side windows here
i get a nice breeze moving all
throughout the van
here is my sink
to turn on the sink you just hit this
switch here and when it's time to dump
my gray water tank which is mounted
underneath the van i just turn that on
so the water supply for the sink is in
this cabinet here which is really easy
access for whenever i need to fill it
and i have two 5 gallon fresh water
tanks
and the gray water tank is mounted right
underneath the van
oh also while we're out here
this is my shoe drawer
this cabinet below the sink
i have
my trash can i use these little
compostable bags and
because it's for compost um it really
holds in any kind of smells and it's
nice and small and compact and fits
perfectly under the sink toilet paper
paper towels under the sink i have these
cleaning supplies um
so like window glass cleaners static
guard which is actually really helpful
when i'm up in mountain towns and
there's a lot of dry air shoe cleaner
this is wood glue which i have had to
use um to fix one of these ceiling
panels that came a little loose and this
totally fixed it and then laundry stuff
which i did want to mention i use true
earth and this is like a year or two
supply worth of laundry detergent magic
erasers which i use to keep all the
cabinets clean
this
a little plunger for my sink i have had
to use this on several occasions so it's
like two bucks totally worth it in the
cabinet next door i have mostly more
cleaning supplies fire spray dish soap
um some cleaning supplies compostable
bags that i mentioned for my garbage
it's reusable grocery bags carbon
monoxide alarm bear spray handles a lint
roller this little broom and dust pan
which i use all day long a hand-held
clothes steamer it's nice to steam your
shirt or steam your dress so that you
don't actually look like you live in
your van in this drawer down here
is my toilet this is a dometic cassette
toilet and i use it for number one only
if you are interested in how one goes
number two in a van like this i did a
whole youtube video on it talking about
toilet shower and laundry i'll link it
around here
campgrounds cafes gas stations grocery
stores the gym um libraries parks and
for the times that i'm out in the middle
of nowhere on like blm or national
forest land i use the bathroom the same
way i would if i fire out tent camping
in the back country i dig it is really
important to note here that not every
place is the same it's super crucial
that you read up on leave no trace lnt
principles it's important to leave a
place as clean as if not cleaner than
when you found it this is the method
that i use when i'm boondocking i have
one ziploc baggie for clean baby wipes
and one for dirty baby wipes and if that
grosses you out then you probably
shouldn't live in a van because even if
you have a compostable toilet like a
nature set or a septic hookup you will
be dealing with your on a regular basis
up in these cabinets i have all my
clothes so
they're in these little gray cubes here
and everything is just rolled so these
are all my shirts you can fit so much
more if you just roll your clothes like
i have an absurd amount of clothing to
be honest but it's no big deal because
it all fits same on this side i have
more clothing bins
and then some shorts and pants and my
toiletry bin which i will show you
contact solution deodorant hair brush
stuff like that face wash um first aid
kit hair stuff and then this is my easy
access bag that i take whenever i'm
taking a shower so it's like toothbrush
contacts that kind of thing and here on
the side i keep my mirror
just opens up like that and the other
cool thing about this mirror is i can
fold it and put it up on my cabinet so
it's eye level when i'm getting ready in
the morning and in this drawer i keep my
camera gear my laptop stuff like that um
i hesitated to show this last time
because i
didn't have a dual lock system on it but
now i do so
yeah i'm sure most of you figured it out
anyway because i said it was just extra
storage this is the office slash bedroom
here i have this table that moves in and
out on a lagoon mount um and this can be
taken off all together and it goes down
to create a queen size bed i got new
pillows these are linen pillow cases and
that might seem like a really small
change but my last pillows were just
plain pillows and these are filled with
my sleeping bags down sleeping bags and
down jackets
and that has given me so much more space
to work with
and storage in plain sight and they're
decorative so it's such a genius idea i
cannot take credit for it um one of you
actually left a comment on my last fan
tour video and suggested that i put like
sweaters and blankets in my pillowcases
and
that's where i got the idea from so
if any of you out there are living in
your car or your vehicle i highly
suggest this hack it's so
amazing like this one
i have a zero degree sleeping bag and
like four dial jackets in here so
yeah it's pretty incredible how much you
can store the cushions are made of
natural latex wrapped in wool and
enclosed in organic waterproof jersey
cotton to prevent moisture the exterior
fabric is cotton canvas my cushions are
three inch latex and i have a separate
one inch latex topper that i roll out on
top
this isn't really necessary but i love
it because it prevents any kind of gap
in the bedding and adds an extra layer
of support to make the bed i remove the
lagoon mount and set it aside insert the
table in the gap between the benches and
move the backrest cushions into the
center
when i first moved into the van i was
setting up the bed and office every
morning and night which takes about five
minutes to do
but in the past six months or so i
started changing it every few days that
said i still would not change this setup
if i were to rebuild i absolutely love
having the option of a dedicated desk
space or table lounge and a bed also i
worked out this super lazy option that
allows me to have a dedicated desk space
here and then a bed here and a day sofa
right there and that works pretty well
for times that i'm just in super hyper
work mode and i don't want to bother
with changing back and forth and just
for reference i'm 5 foot 9 and from this
end to this end on the tightest spot
it's 6 feet across i opted for a linen
duvet and sheet set which was kind of
pricey but totally worth it it's super
soft and also breathable which is
important with the wide range of
temperatures you experience living in a
van
underneath each cushion is a window
cover and these have been a new addition
to the van i highly highly recommend
them they're made by van made gear and
they completely black out the van when i
cover up the back windows and the side
windows there's magnets sewn into the
lining all the way around and there's
reflectix sewn into it as well so it
keeps the van both cool and warm
depending on the situation
sticks right there and from the outside
it's a complete blackout it doesn't let
any light out and the cool thing
you can also go like that and so you
don't have to have additional storage
for it under the large cushion here i
have the window cover for the side
window and it just snaps into place
super easy this also rolls up and snaps
just like the other ones
which is super convenient if you don't
want to find storage for it someplace
else i also have
these window covers
they have reflectix sewn into them and
they fit snug in my little windowsills
in the back and so they black out those
back windows with all of these window
covers in place and blackout curtain
which i'll show you guys a little bit
and the black foam piece for the dometic
fan it's a complete blackout in here
like i've turned on the lights and shut
the van walked outside and there isn't
any light emitting from the whole van
coming back to the benches underneath
the cushions i have bench storage here
is my
down pillow
here's my duvet cover it i store it in a
pillow case so that it will stay nice
down there and then here i have an extra
wool blanket
sheets and this is my
one inch latex mattress topper under
this large cushion i have access to
these three different compartments which
i can also access from the back doors
this door right here is where i keep all
of my camping supplies um i have an
extra tripod i have a tent
i have my drone and my first aid kit
stuff like that down there i also have
this solar shower which it's just a
black bag and you fill it up with water
like from a stream or a lake and you can
lay it in the sun and then
use it as a shower and just like hang it
so that's a pretty neat addition in this
little door i keep my hiking boots and
my running shoes and on this side i have
most of my linens which i showed you
earlier and then here on the door is my
wii boost what this does is it amplifies
my cell signal so if i head out to the
boonies or blm or national forest and
only have one or two bars of lte there
is an interior antenna and then there's
also an antenna mounted on the top of
the van that will boost my signal and
allow me to work in remote locations
here's where i have the internal antenna
for the wii boost and whenever i want a
stronger internet connection i just
plug into dc volt so it doesn't require
very much power
and yeah it boosts my signal and these
hat hooks are new additions um i can't
believe i didn't have them before it was
just wasted space and it was such a
inexpensive upgrade in this compartment
my suitcase for
plane travel which hasn't happened much
lately but hopefully soon i have a
ridiculous amount of shoes in this van
which one day i'll show you when i'm
doing a walkthrough of my wardrobe it's
kind of embarrassing how many shoes i
have this is flozyme which are enzymes
that i put down my sink every once in a
while to keep it from smelling and i
have my leveling blocks down there which
are great for getting the van nice and
flat and in this compartment here
i have a lot of miscellaneous things i
have three of these storage bags and i
find them really handy i can throw
dresses and sweaters and just additional
clothing in them and they stack really
well inside of these benches i have
additional toiletries which i probably
don't need but you know like a hair
straightener and a year supply of
contacts that's important i could
probably live without this stuff but i
have space for it so yeah that lives
down here which is a bunch of other
random stuff another place where i have
lots of storage is this overhead storage
compartment here it goes all the way up
to the windshield and i can fit so many
jackets and technical gear
during the off season my backpacking bag
which is currently living in my front
seat
easily fits back there in the corner um
i have climbing gear just all kinds of
stuff up there i've also started using
this overhead storage bin for
towels for the beach um little bags for
you know like knickknacks i have my
covers there another down jacket here's
another van life essential the
walkie-talkies like when i'm traveling
with a caravan with friends and there's
no
um service these are great to stay in
touch these are sand cloud towels and i
have two of them up there and i
absolutely love them they repel sand so
if you take them to a beach you can lay
them out and then just shake them and
they're good to go so they're really
world life friendly this is my gym bag
on a carabiner
and down here i keep my camera bag so my
shower bag isn't really anything special
i just have this little shower tote um
and i just refill the shampoo and
conditioner this is a quick dry towel
which
after i shower i just hang it on the
back of my chair for like i don't know a
few hours and then it's totally dry and
i also have this compact hair dryer
which is actually ancient i've had it
since i lived in europe so it is kind of
falling apart but
super handy and easy to travel with this
is the peak design everyday pack and it
stores my drone all my lenses two
cameras and my laptop and ipad so this
is what i take into coffee shops
whenever i'm going in for a full day's
work next to the shower bag i have my
hanging laundry bag and this is just a
canvas bag that i've had literally since
college my rolled up yoga mat and below
i have rain boots because washington and
here is an ice scraper a helmet hanging
for my bike below the driver's seat is a
pretty substantial amount of space and
down here i keep all of my tools here is
an overview of what i have stored
underneath the driver's seat so i just
have some basic tools windshield repair
kit screwdriver tape tape measure
a wrench kit and i have caulking for my
tile i have this noco genius starter
which allows me to jump start my vehicle
without the help of another car which is
super handy spare rv latches a tool kit
for my bike this 12 volt portable air
compressor which allows me to fill up my
tires if they're running a little low on
air or also deflate them if i'm going to
be on certain kinds of terrain over here
i have a lot of warranty information and
instruction manuals
screwdriver sets spare batteries here i
have my blackout curtain it's gray on
this side and then black on the other
side
so if you're looking into the van at
night you're just going to see black and
i use this magnet
to secure it over on this side so that
no light gets out in the front seat
right now since i'm filming i have my
guitar
which
guys i'm still not any good at playing
it but i try
i finally have calluses on my finger so
that counts for something right but um
typically i would store it right behind
my passenger seat but since i got the
bike i now just put it in the back um on
one of the cushions under a pillow and
i'm driving and it stays there just fine
but seriously i promise one day i'm
gonna play a ben howard song for you
guys
it might be terrible but i'm gonna try
in this corner it used to be a giant
styrofoam piece and i got bored one day
and ripped it out
so
i don't know what that was
this is what i keep in there now it is a
rolled towel
and
i love it in my passenger seat i
mentioned this briefly earlier but
during hiking season which is like all
of summer and most of all i have my
backpack always fully packed with like a
sleeping bag sleeping mat pillow
it's full of three liters of water
everything i need so that when i roll up
to a campsite and i want to go for a
hike it's just ready to go beneath the
passenger seat is one of the newest
additions to the van an s bar petrol
heater along with a 12 volt power
temperature monitor i spent the first
two and a half years on the road without
a heater so this has been a huge upgrade
for me this is the high altitude model
which means it can function in high
elevations you can find the exact link
to it on my gear page it draws gas from
my vans fuel tank so i don't need to
hook up a separate fuel source to keep
it going and the exhaust pipe is mounted
beneath the van it's extremely efficient
every time i've used it i haven't even
noticed the fuel gauge dropping at all
when i start the engine also the
passenger seat has a swivel package
i can swivel this around and kick up and
have an extra place to hang out or have
an extra seat for friends in the van i
have a folding e-bike and it lives right
behind that passenger seat
it does take up a lot of space i haven't
decided if i'm going to keep it in there
um throughout the winter months when i
want to use the heater but we'll see i
might get a mount for it on the bike i
absolutely love the bike so i am
really just putting up with how much
space it takes up because i think it's
worth it when i roll up to a campsite i
take it out and unfold it and lock it up
behind the van so i got a u-lock
that connects to the van down here and
then i have
this lock here so it's
locked up pretty good it's accessible
and gives me a lot more space inside the
van when i bought the van it came with
some pretty small factory wheels and
tires and i was reluctant about
switching them out because i don't know
i just hated the idea of wasting
perfectly good tires but after a year
and a half i finally opted for an
upgrade from the awesome team over at
landed gear in san diego they custom cut
the rear wheel well to fit new bf
goodrich 245 ko2 tires and new wheels
and rams they also added their flagship
tire mount here in the back and swapped
out the factory suspension for sumo
suspension springs this allowed for a
little more ground clearance and a much
smoother ride down bumpy forest roads
here in the passenger front seat i am
typically storing firewood and a hatchet
and yet another pair of shoes
here on the side door i keep a lot of
day packs my packable shovel and this is
something that i use really often when
i'm out national forest or blm land on
the driver's side i just have more
storage so in here i have wasp spray and
fire extinguishing spray um i have a
u-lock for my bike mosquito screens for
my sliding door my back doors and my
side doors compartment up here i have an
additional inverter head lamp and car
fresheners gotta keep that fresh fresh
here in the front seat under the visor i
have this folding mirror
which is super handy when i want to do
my makeup up in the front seat with
natural light with my little co-pilot
plant and my dream catcher that i got in
the grand canyon another small storage
hack that i use is i have these little
brass shower curtain rings and i just
put them on the back of my seats here
and then i can hang a jacket or sweater
or a little backpack
and also i use hair ties for
rolling up technical gear or bags like
this day pack that i use
i can roll it up and use a hair tie and
then it stores really easily overall i'm
really happy with how the van is held up
over the past two years as far as wear
and tear goes there are some parts in
the van where some cracks are starting
to show and i probably need to sand them
down and repaint them um and this table
right here depending on what environment
i'm in it can warp pretty significantly
but now that i'm back in washington it
seems to be flattening out a bit which i
like
the same goes
with this cutting board this can warp so
much it'll be like practically bowed but
if i get back into a humid environment
it'll go flat again some of the counters
have a bit of wear and tear um just from
being used all the time and the floor
definitely has some scratches i
mentioned before one of these um ceiling
slats did come down but i was able to
fix that with wood glue so no big deal
there behind the fridge there is some
warped and cracked paint so i do think
that maybe i have some water leaking at
times where there's a lot of moisture so
that's one thing that i probably need to
get fixed those little black rv latches
that i use on the cabinets and drawers
that i showed you those have all broken
at least once so i keep those on hand
and oh one other common question i get
is do i feel like i have enough power
have i ever run out of power and i did
once i fell asleep with an electric
blanket plugged into the ac all night so
the inverter was on and i woke up to my
lights being out so that was my fault um
apart from that i've never even come
close to running out of power between my
320 solar watts and the dc to dc charger
i have more than enough power all right
so that's about it um thank you so much
for watching this tour i know it was
really long but
if you have any additional questions or
comments um just leave them in the
comment section below i always love
hearing from you guys
and like i mentioned earlier if you're
interested in anything that i talked
about in this tour check out my link
christian shaffer dot art slash gear
that's where i have all my
recommendations and affiliate links
listed for the products in this van and
whenever you use those links i get a
small kickback and it keeps me out here
creating so thank you so much i really
appreciate you guys if you like this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
if you're interested in
travel photography or van life um i post
irregularly but i'm working on that i
appreciate you guys so much thank you
for being here and i'll see you out on
that open road
[Music]
so
[Music]
you